entre lágrimas y abrazos 31 niños
ucranianos se reencontraron con sus
familias en la frontera con belaruz
en parte de la quinta misión de rescate
de menores ucranianos que habían sido
llevados por las tropas rusas hacia
campamentos en territorios bajo control
de Moscú como la Península de crimea
yura de 15 años Fue separado de forma
violenta de su madre y trasladado a
campamento rusos donde pasó cinco meses
recluido denuncia que intentaron
adoctrinarlo e inculcarle los valores
rusos
nos hacían poner de pie cuando sonaba el
himno ruso los que no lo hacíamos como
yo teníamos que escribir notas
explicativas tuve que escribir al
director Por qué no me puse de pie
cuando sonaba simplemente les dije que
no lo quería cantar
las operaciones de rescate pusieron en
peligro a varias madres que atravesaron
Polonia belarus y Rusia para encontrar a
sus hijos algunas madres no
sobrevivieron otras como Natalia rack
por fin pueden expresar alegría al
abrazar a sus hijos
fue muy emotivo ver a los niños y a las
madres juntos otra vez
todo el estrés que vivimos pero ahora
gracias a Dios todo ha terminado ya
estamos en Ucrania
niños de misiones de rescate anteriores
se reunieron con la ong savio crane al
mando de las operaciones es el inicio de
un proceso de duelo
nos trataban como animales estábamos
encerrados en un edificio aislado todos
los días se nos decían que nuestros
padres nos rechazaron y que no nos
querían
en marzo la Corte Penal Internacional
emitió una orden de arresto contra el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin y la
comisionada de derechos de los niños de
Rusia acusándolos de secuestrar niños
ucranianos cerca de
19.500 niños fueron raptados según
Fuentes ucranianas Rusia ha negado las
acusaciones y dice que la orden de
arresto es nula y sin efecto